what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with night terrors and I'm
curious to see how you guys feel about
the ending of this because it's a little
wonky
so what this does is this initially
opens up with a young girl who basically
wakes up from a dream and for those of
you guys who are just joining us the
long and short of Night Terrors is that
there was a guy or there is a guy named
insomnia whose family died during a
fight between these evil version of
Batman basically and the Justice League
right the building collapsed and they
were killed and so on and so forth
because of that he took what was
previously called the dreamstone which
allowed a person to manipulate Reality
by bringing their dreams into the real
world and then in turn once it had
become the nightmare Stone used it for
his own ends and we'll kind of talk a
little bit more about that as we get
further through this story but with this
girl waking up after the entire world
had been put to sleep initially her
nightmares were kind of dismissed by her
parents right when she talks about like
the evil justice league and so on and so
forth but then she refers to the man
with no eyelids who of course we know is
insomnia her parents saw the exact same
guy that of course is also dismissed to
a degree but then we suddenly have this
moment where these kind of nightmare
members of the Justice League are yanked
into the real world by insomnia himself
and so following that the rest of the
Justice League responds exactly as you
would expect them to and it's not even
just the Justice League it's the Justice
League and like a whole host of Heroes
which also includes Sandman now again I
called it before that as soon as they
brought Sandman back right as soon as
Wesley Dodge showed back up I was like
okay they're gonna basically find a way
to bring him back and that is in effect
what they are going to do although
you'll see as we get further through
this seemingly exactly how they're going
to do it but insomnia making his move he
actually ends up using Boston brand and
what he does is he kind of talks about
this idea that Boston Brand himself is
kind of the guy that made all this
possible and in reality it's true it was
never the intention of dead man to do
that right the intention of dead man was
to possess Batman and then eventually
enter into the mind of insomnia and then
basically try to find a way to defeat
him but by bringing the nightmare Stone
directly to him him he literally gave
him exactly what he was looking for it
was just one gigantic ruse and so what
he does sort of toying with Boston Brand
it says look this all went according to
plan you made all this happen let me
give you your just reward and what he
ends up doing is he actually ends up
presenting Boston Brand with his own
family after kind of putting him into a
bit of a trance possibly even sleeping
technically Boston Brand is dead so he
doesn't really sleep but the fact
remains that he's sort of brought in by
this whole thing kind of Hoodwinked
right by like this family that he
imagines himself having having some
measure of normalcy in this life that is
otherwise abnormal and what I mean by
that is when it comes to Boston bran and
we haven't really talked about him too
much he is quite literally a dead guy
right he's basically a ghost and he's
kind of doomed to seemingly spend
eternity just watching these individuals
living their lives but never actually
being able to join their lives at all so
it is a really interesting role possibly
cursed I guess it really depends on how
you look at it but the one thing he's
always longed for is a family of his own
and he basically gets it and so it kind
of takes him out of commission for a
temporary period of time now following
that the rest of the Justice League
basically responds with dead man out of
the equation and tries to defeat him
like where they can when they can but
there's not a whole lot they can do here
right now one of the things that I also
want to draw your attention to this is
written by some top-notch writers over a
DC Comics right chip zadarski Matt
Rosenberg and so on but it doesn't feel
like it right because it's one of these
things where it's kind of written almost
like a campy 1960s type of story which I
guess maybe it's been this way up to
this point but it just kind of feels
more noticeable now than it has in the
past but at the end of the day it
doesn't really matter right the Justice
League cannot overtake this guy they
can't beat this guy as easily as they
had hoped and so it's one of these
things where he even makes a kind of
mockery of like the Hall of Heroes right
like you guys keep trophies from your
accomplishment from the various villains
that you've defeated what kind of Heroes
need trophies right let me present you
with my trophies and then forces them to
fight their own nightmarish versions of
themselves now one of the things that I
do want to specify here is that these
nightmarish versions have appeared in
their own individual dreams but they are
basically opposites right caricatures of
their actual selves and so it's
interesting to see the Justice League
fighting kind of like their evil
counterparts if you want to call it that
but even when you have Wesley Dodge
trying to wake up Boston bran from this
kind of Trance type experience
eventually he does right he starts to
realize this whole thing is a nightmare
none of it's real and basically starts
to move away from it and then
immediately goes after insomnia and in
fact he almost kind of leans into his
punishment right even going so far as to
say I gave up on that kind of Life a
long time ago long before I died in fact
and so in that moment Boston Brand is
like seized by insomnia and Force
Academy kind of experience this sort of
horrendous life that he lives right he
says this is you alone I see you were
already living your nightmare before you
always crave the spotlight and that was
taken along with your life so you've
been trapped as this audience forced to
watch others live never able to move on
and the response of Boston is if I'm
trapped here then I'll make sure you're
trapped with me and so this is a very
important moment because now the fight
suddenly just takes place between
insomnia and Boston bran we don't really
see a whole lot of it instead you just
kind of transition to the various
superheroes who are facing off against
their evil demonic selves I mean there's
not really a whole lot doing here it's
kind of interesting a little bit but not
really overly important but between
Boston bran and insomnia this is
interesting because Boston's response is
like you're letting the nightmare Stone
corrupt you it called for you it wanted
you to free it I felt it too it played
on my anger left over from when I die
dot but the response of insomnia is but
what did you lose your life the
spotlight that's it I lost everything
now something that I want to specify
here and this is what's really
interesting when it comes to the
different perceptions of Boston Brand
and insomnia it's a matter of priorities
it's a matter of significance what
matters the most and the mind of
insomnia the most important thing that
he had was his family right it was his
wife and it was his two kids they were
everything right and like any father
who's any measure of a father he would
willingly give his life for his family
in order to keep them safe I can't
imagine any kind of a father and husband
who wouldn't do that but for Boston
Brand it was really just kind of him
living his life with a goal out there
that was never ever achieved right
unfinished business if we want to
reference the Casper film from back in
the 1990s but the important distinction
here is that each of these guys views
their own individual life or their own
individual loss as a seemingly imp
important thing and they're trying to
make comparisons right they're kind of
trying to equal these two things out
right like this is equal to this and so
on and so forth but it's all a matter of
perception right they're literally
fighting over who's struggled the most
and so the response of dead man is
nothing is going to bring your family
back insomnia this does not honor them
please let's stop this together and
insomnia's response is you're right the
world knows the truth now I won but
that's not enough the Justice League
could have saved my family and they
didn't I know how to honor my family I
punish the heroes and so what you end up
getting is the Justice League that
transitions to Arkham where they
basically pick up with John D now John
D's a character that has been referenced
heavily over the course of this story
but he's also incredibly obscure unless
you're like a super hardcore DC Comics
fan so the idea behind John D is this is
basically Dr Destiny and Dr Destiny was
a guy who had come into possession of
the dreamstone at some point on the line
and then had corrupted it and turned it
into the nightmare Stone but he was
fearful of what it was capable of and
that's why he hid it because if a person
were able to attain the nightmare Stone
and use it for their own ends you'd see
exactly what you're seeing now this
person using the nightmares of the world
and bringing them into reality it's
horrifying right just because of the
Pure Imagination that takes place in our
subconscious When We're Dreaming right
it's 100 pure unadulterated imagination
that's it we can't even control it right
so if your subconscious just kind of
dreams these wild and crazy Concepts up
and somebody in possession of The
Nightmare Stone decides to bring those
things into reality that could lead to
the destruction of anything and
everything and in fact it could even
lead to the destruction of all reality
so it's no small wonder why this guy got
rid of this thing right try to hide it
between realities in a place that no
body could access and so what you end up
having is Batman presenting this to
Wesley Dodds who decides to take it
right he says allow me I always felt a
connection to it I always dreamed of
being part of something bigger now
that's an important bit of sandman's
History Right Wesley Dodds was always
the guy who wanted to be a part of like
the greater superhero Community he never
really was right but even beyond the
superhero Community itself ever since
his first encounter with dream of the
Endless he always kind of wanted to walk
among the gods so even when he was part
of the Justice Society of America he was
a person who was able to contribute to
the team but he was never really a
powered being in the sense that he
wasn't really powered like the original
Green Lantern Alan Scott right or the
original flash Jay Garrick or Dr Fate or
somebody along those lines but even in
the midst of all of this try as they
might they all find themselves corrupted
by the power of insomnia because he says
you think you can can handle the
dreamstone's power Wesley Dodds you're
nothing but some old zombie you're out
of your league now the whole world sees
the heroes like I do as monsters and
there's a bit of bickering back and
forth between the two of them but Wesley
Dodds makes this really good case where
he says that nightmare Stone should
never be in the real world insomnia and
that where insomnia himself responds by
saying like give it to me or I'll kill
you like I kill dead man of course we
end up finding out the dead man is
actually alive right he just kind of
faked his death it was a great big huge
Rouge that kind of thing and he ends up
seizing control of insomnia himself and
basically dragging him back into
arguably the nightmare realm the
afterlife whatever you want to call it
and it's a bit murky here because
technically insomnia is not dead right
he's not a guy who is deceased he's a
living person who effectively augmented
himself using a combination of the
powers that he got from the whole
Lazarus Planet event when he was doused
with the Lazarus Pit chemicals and
gained abilities along with what he's
now doing which is the nightmare Stone
but by seizing him Boston bran kind of
throws him into this realm and then
Boston Brand enters as well and it
really gives the implication that he's
going on to the afterlife he says it's
time I went on a new adventure Wesley my
deal with ramakrishna was over lifetimes
ago for those of you guys who don't know
what that means when Boston bran was
killed right because he was literally
murdered he ended up striking a deal
with ramakrishna who's a character
that's part of like the John
Constantine's a ton of Mythos in DC
right like all that kind of magic and
mysticism and that she would give him
the ability to basically achieve his
revenge he did but then he's also kind
of lingered ever since and so that's
what he's referencing right he says I'm
sick of being in the audience no more
watching The Living I need to be the
star again don't you hear it they're
cheering for me and so it's almost like
he kind of dies right now insomnia
himself falls into what really is his
own nightmare although arguably you
could say he basically ends up falling
into hell but he wakes up surrounded by
his family right the people that he
misses the most only for them to turn
into the kind of like their nightmare
selves to start chewing on him consuming
him so on and so forth then you get like
Flames fire and all that kind of good
stuff so it really looks like he was
just taken to Hell by dead man and he's
just gonna spend eternity there because
for those of you guys who aren't
familiar with that heaven and hell do
exist in DC Comics that is a part of
their Mythos the judeo-christian
philosophy of like the afterlife that's
a very big part of like the whole entire
other side of the superhero landscape in
DC but following that for Wesley Dodds
the questions asked by zatana whether or
not he's ready to basically go back to
his life right or really go back to
being dead right his missions more or
less quote unquote done and so of course
you have her kind of casting the spell
you rest in peace and then he basically
goes back to slumbering and then of
course Batman passes out because dead
man had basically pushed his body to the
brink by keeping him not really awake
but by keeping his body from being able
to rest the way it normally does when
we're sleeping no one really knows when
he's going to recover so that's going to
kind of feed into the Batman stories
maybe Damien Wayne will end up becoming
Batman and instead not entirely sure but
for Sandman Wesley this is where things
get interesting because I think this
story in a lot of ways will draw
interest to his character word didn't
previously exist whether or not that
would see a successful solo series I'm
not entirely sure but apparently he's
getting one so I will go so far as to
argue that Sandman solo series is just
gonna be like the Lost Tales of Wesley
Dodds things that he was doing before he
died and if that proves to be popular DC
is going to be like and he's back
through like whatever means comic book
logic and that's basically it but the
bigger conversation here takes place
between like Mr terrific Wonder Woman
and Superman when they talk about how
like the day saved insomnia has been
defeated but everything feels so wrong
and the statement of Wonder Woman is
it's because we didn't win today right
insomnia did because he got exactly what
he wanted people are now terrified of
the Justice League this little girl that
we talked about at the beginning of the
story starts taking down these little
drawings that she had made for the
Justice League of America her these
Heroes these Heroes as she kind of
idolized she more or less sees them as
horrifying things people have lost faith
in them now this is when the ending of
the story gets
what we in the comic book scene refer to
as goofy so what this does is it
transitions over to Amanda Waller that's
not the goofy part Amanda Waller is
amazing right Amanda Waller's just
absolutely awesome but what she talks
about is that like the tides turning
right that like Society is kind of
turning against the Justice League of
America and she talks about how insomnia
had actually given two gifts the first
was the helmet of hate on Lazarus Island
the ability to channel the hate of
various people who were out there and
then of course the nightmare Stone which
was stolen during all the chaos and all
the pandemonium but somebody out there
whose identity is a total mystery
basically talks about how they want to
use these things right this person says
I need to see that they can't just use
smiles to solve all our problems that's
not real right that's like the only real
motivation that we get so Amanda Waller
hands the helmet and the nightmare Stone
over to this person who fuses the two of
them together and then refers to
themselves as Dr hate uh the outfit and
everything looks pretty dope but the
whole thing feels kind of dumb so I'm
sort of curious to see where DC goes
with it but with that being said guys
let me know down in the comments how you
feel about this story I feel like I
already know what you guys are going to
say if you want to get caught up on
night terrors make sure you click this
link to the playlist and I will catch
you all later
peace